i don't know if you're familiar with uh
donald hoffman's work about reality
so his idea is that we're just our
perception is just an interface to
reality
so donald hoffman is the uh is the guide
uc irvine
yeah yes i've met donaldson and i've
seen this video and look
donald has not invented anything new
this goes back to
ancient philosophy let me just stating
yeah yes
in case people aren't familiar i mean
it's a fascinating thought experiment to
me
like of out of the box thinking perhaps
literally is that
uh you know our there's a different
there's a
gap between the world as we perceive it
and the world as it actually exists
and i think that's for the philosophy
objectivism is a really important
gap to close so can you
maybe at least try to entertain the idea
that
that there is more to reality than our
minds can perceive
well i don't understand what more means
right of course there's more to reality
than what our senses perceive
that is uh for example i don't know
certain
certain elements uh have uh radiation
right uranium hazard i can't perceive
radiation
the beauty of human reason is i can
i can through experimentation discover
the phenomena of radiation then
actually measure radiation and i don't
worry about it i can't perceive the
world the way a bad perceives the world
and i might not be able to see certain
things
that but i can we've created radar so a
we understand how our bad perceives the
world
and i can mimic it through a radar
screen and create an images like the bat
its consciousness somehow perceives it
right so
the beauty of human reason is our
capacity to understand
the world beyond what our senses give us
directly at the end everything comes in
through our senses but
we can understand things that our senses
don't provide us but but what he's doing
is
he's doing something very different he
is saying what our census provides us
might have nothing to do with the
reality out there
that is just a random arbitrary
nonsensical
statement and he actually has a whole
evolutionary explanation for it he runs
some
simulations the simulation seem i mean
i'm not an expert in this field but
they seem silly to me they they don't
seem to reflect and look all he's doing
is taking imano akan's philosophy
which articulate exactly the same cause
and he's giving it
a veneer of of of evolutionary
uh ideas i'm not an expert on evolution
and i'm not an expert
on epistemology which is what this is so
to me
as as a semi layman it doesn't make any
sense
and uh you know i i'm actually
you know i have a i have this year on
book show i don't know if i'm allowed to
pitch it but i've got this
bookshelf first of all let me pause on
youtube
i listen to it very often as a small
aside
the cool thing about reason which you
practice
is you have a systematic way of thinking
through basically
anything yes and that's so fun to listen
to
i mean it's rare that i think there's
flaws in your logic
but even then it's fun because i'm like
disagreeing with the screen
and it's great when somebody disagrees
with me and they give good arguments
because that makes it challenging yeah
yeah you know so so one of the shows i
want to do in the next few weeks is
is one of my philosophy being one of my
philosophers friends to discuss
the video that that hoffman uh where he
presents his tv because
it surprises me how seductive it is
and it seems to be so first of all
completely counterintuitive but
but because you know somehow we managed
to cross the road and not get hit by the
car and if our
our senses did not provide us any
information about what's actually going
on in reality
how do we do that that's and not not to
mention build computers
not to mention flights to the moon and
actually land on the moon and if reality
is not giving us
information about the moon if our
sensors are not giving us information
about the moon
how did we get there you know and what
did where did we go maybe we didn't go
anyway
um it's just it's nonsensical to me and
it's
it's a it's a very bad place
uh philosophically because it basically
says there is no objective standard for
anything
there's no objective reality you can
come up with anything you could argue
anything and there's no methodology
right my
i believe that at the end of the day
what reason allows us to do is provides
us with a methodology for truth and at
the end of the day for every claim that
i make
i should be able to boil it down to
see yeah look the evidence of the census
is right then once you take that away
knowledge is gone and truth is gone and
that opens it up to
you know complete disaster so you know
to me why it's compelling
to at least entertain this idea
first of all it shakes up the mind a
little bit to
force you to go back to first principles
and you know ask the question what do i
really know
and the second part of that that i
really enjoy
is it's a reminder that we know very
little
to be a little bit more humble so if
reality doesn't exist at all
before you start thinking about it i
think it's a really
nice wake-up call to think wait a minute
i don't really know much about this
universe that humbleness
i think something i'd like to ask you
about in terms of reason
when you you can become very confident
in your ability to understand the world
if you practice reason often
and i feel like it can lead you astray
because you can start to think it's so i
love psychology
and psychologists have this certainty
about
understanding the human condition which
is undeserved
you know you're on a study with 50
people and you think you could
understand
the source of all these psychiatric
disorders all these kinds of things
that's similar kind of trouble i feel
like you can get
into with when you when you overreach
with reason
so i don't think there is such a thing
as overreaching with reason but there
are bad applications of reason
they're bad uses of reason or or the
pretense of using reason i think a lot
of these psychological
studies are pretense of using reason and
and uh
these psychologists have never really
taken a serious stat class or a serious
econometrics class so they use
statistics in weird ways
they just don't make any sense and
that's a mis that's not reason
right that's that's just bad thinking
right so i
i don't think you can do too much good
thinking
and that's what reason is it's good
thinking and now
that the fact that you
try to use reason does not guarantee you
won't make mistakes
it doesn't guarantee you won't be wrong
it doesn't guarantee you won't go down a
rabbit hole
and and completely get it wrong but it
does give you the only existing
mechanism to fix it
right which is going back to reality
going back to facts going back to reason
and and and getting out of the rabbit
hole and getting up back to
reality so i agree with you
that it's interesting to think about
these
what i consider crazy ideas because it
oh wait
what is my argument about them if i
don't really have a good argument about
them
then do i know what i know so in that
sense it's always nice to be challenged
and pushed
and and oriented you know the nice thing
about objectivism is
everybody's doing that to me all the
time right because nobody agrees with me
on anything so
i'm constantly being challenged whether
it's in
by hoffman on metaphysics and
epistemology right on the very
foundations of my knowledge and ethics
everybody constantly
and in in politics all the time so um
i find that it's part of you know i
prefer that everybody
there's a sense in which i prefer that
everybody agreed with me right because i
think we'd live in a better world
but there's a sense in which that
disagreement makes it at least up to a
point
makes it interesting and challenging and
forces you
to be able to to rethink or to confirm
your own thinking and to challenge that
thinking
you